عشت في الاوطان للعلى عنوان
احضروا بلجيكا اطلبوا اسبانيا استنجد
برونالدو الاسود موجوده في المونديال
لتبقى واعرينها لم يستقبل الا هدفا واحدا
زئير الاسود مستمر في كاس العالم شاء من
شاء وابا من اباه المغرب يفوز ويواصل
كتابه التاريخ اول فريق افريقي وعربي يبلغ
نصف نهائي كاس العالم
ويسطرمه بين الاربعه الكبار المغرب لعب
بعشره لاعبين بعد طرد المفاجئ ان المهاجم
وليد الشديره قبل خمس دقائق من النهايه
ضغط الاعصاب وحبس الانفاس سلسال دفاعيا ثم
انفراج مع صافره النهايه ومع انجاز
الانتقال للمربع الذهبي الكاس لم يعد حلما
180 دقيقه تفصل المملكه المغربيه والمنطقه
عن المعجزه
متران و 78 سم هو الارتفاع الذي ارتقى
اليه يوسف مصيري قبل راسيته المذهله في
الشوط الاول والتي كانت كفيله للاطاحه
بالبرتغال في اخر مشاركه لكريستيانو
رونالدو في المونديال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اليوم كثير اول مره في التاريخ يتاهل فريق
عربي وفريق افريقي اول مره في تاريخ كره
القدم اوه
وكشكرون اللعابه على المجهودات رونالدو
ما شاء الله عليهم ما شاء الله حمر
والنوجانا رايك في المنتخب المغربي
مغامر كبير تبارك الله عليه واللي عنده
المغرب بكار و رونالدو
[موسيقى]
لو كنتمنى اول يوم مسيره موفقه ان شاء
الله ان شاء الله نديو الكاس على شله
الخير
[تصفيق]